Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimari yo!
Ruffians, what did you think of our new jingle?
Thank you so much, Aina!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
For introductions, I'm Nanachihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 18th episode!
BAU BAU BAU BAU.
18 episodes.
18.
Well, Ruffians, you know, I saw a couple Ruffians that maybe this was their first time for FUWAMOCO Morning today.
So to explain FUWAMOCO Morning, it is a short format morning show.
And it's held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FUWAMOCO Morning.
FWMC Morning.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning.
BAU BAU!
So first, we have another Pero Sighting.
Another Ruffian found Pero.
This is good.
This is good, but let's see.
Oh!
Cute!
Pero was spotted in a UFO catcher!
That's pretty fun.
Don't bother fishing it out!
You know, look, there's the cute blue monster in the front.
There's so many better things than him in real life.
Yeah, like the white alien with the pretty pink toes.
Maybe grab those instead.
The pink toes.
Yeah, you know.
Actually, Ruffians, here's a gift.
Windows for us.
Not Pero.
The other ones.
The other ones, the cute ones.
You know, the ones that actually have value to them.
Those ones, you know.
Although, you know, we're actually pretty strong when it comes to UFO catchers, okay?
Yeah, we really, really, really like UFO catchers.
Have you done that before, Ruffians?
We haven't.
No.
We've never.
We'd like to try though.
Right, we'd like to try it together with you.
It just seems dangerous.
Yeah, you know we've never done it because we always feel like we might get a bit hooked.
But I think when it comes to UFO catches, we really like to win the cute plushies the most, you know?
Sometimes, you know, we try to watch some videos on YouTube to learn all the tricks from special YouTubers who do that sort of stuff.
But I think the kind of trick is you have to use your brain.
You have to think of interesting ways to win a bet.
Yeah, you have to look at all the corners and stuff, right?
That's what makes it really fun.
And then sometimes, when you win, you can make new cute friends.
That's why they're the best, you know?
I hope that we can enjoy UFO Catches all together sometime.
But, yeah, Pero.
Pero, right?
He's important.
He's in this photo, right?
He can just kinda stay there, right?
Yeah, he can hang out.
It'll be good.
Oh, he makes a good pushy.
Maybe, you know, he'll find a layout soon.
Maybe some poor kid comes along and fishes him out?
That's too bad for them.
I think any other prize would be better.
Maybe no prize might be better.
Ruffians!
Please let us know if you see Pero around again, okay?
Remember to use the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
BAU BAU!
And today we actually have some
HAPPY NEWS!
Yeah, happy news.
You know, yesterday, after our Donkey Kong Country stream, we happened to pop into Mumei's stream to tell her she was joining us and all of Abyss!
Ruffians, did you see?
Did you see?
We kind of redirected into Mumei's stream, but still... But we didn't expect that.
Right?
We were really so, so, so, so happy to be able to do that, you know?
Mumei-senpai's drawings are really amazing.
Actually, kinda really scare us too.
They scare me!
Do you remember how Mumei-senpai's special scare does?
A boy in holo-cure.
It was really really really scary.
Maybe Moco-chan, let's see how the illustrations are going.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Nightmares!
Oh well, Mumei-senpai said you know that they have like a strong soccer dog mom feeling to them, right?
I don't know what to think about that, but... Maybe, you know, one day this is what Moco-chan will look like when she has a team full of puppies and I have my own team of puppies and we could, you know, battle them out.
Against each other in a game of soccer.
Right.
He's gonna sound like Pokemon.
Really?
I don't know.
Maybe it's a bit more like a nightmare?
Or a strange dream?
A strange dream at least.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Which one?
Is she violent?
Well, you know.
Might get that really good.
Huh?
It'd be good if this stayed a dream.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Ruffians are okay with it though.
I don't want to have a team of puppies.
No team of puppies?
No reality, not like this.
How many puppies would you need to fill a soccer team?
How many members are on a soccer team?
Ten or more.
Eleven.
Why is it not an even number?
I don't like that.
Yeah, this doesn't need to be reality.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Mumei-senpai!
We're looking forward to it.
BAU BAU!
And that was our happy news.
Good to start the day with some happy news.
What comes with happy news?
More happy news, right?
Sad news.
Ruffians.
So also, yesterday.
The good news happened and the bad news happened both yesterday.
There was a casualty!
A death!
I know we talked about no casualties, but there was.
There was, yeah.
Moco-chan's chair.
It was a sacrifice to Donkey Kong.
I died that one time and then I became one with the floor.
I got back up, but then I broke the arm of my chair off.
You know, all the screws just fell out and I tried fixing it today because it's really bugging me, but I don't have the screwdriver that works for it.
The screws.
That's what a screwdriver does.
So they just keep on falling out after I try to screw them in with my hands.
I'm doing my best but it's not working.
And you know, to be honest, the other arm, the arm that I still have, it's only held in by one screw too.
So, I might end up with no arms very soon.
It's just a seat at that point, right?
It's just a seat.
Hopefully I'm still left with a seat.
But hopefully I can fix it soon.
You know, it's important to have a good, proper chair for your health, Ruffians.
Yeah, at least have a good seat with a back.
Yeah, let's focus on the half because it still has the bottom part of the seat.
Yeah, and I still have my arms.
My chair might not have much arms left, but I still have my arms.
I didn't try to break it.
He gave up.
He fell apart.
It's Donkey Kong's fault, right?
Yeah, yeah.
He was... He was... Yeah, that's it.
Good luck, chair!
Good luck, me!
BAU BAU!
Actually, the sad news doesn't just stop there.
There's been
Another misunderstanding.
And this one is pretty big.
Yeah, you know, it's a very serious misunderstanding.
Something, you know, something we absolutely, at all costs, must clear up with you ruffians, okay?
It's something that's been happening here on every single FUWAMOCO Morning.
Something bad.
Almost every episode.
You didn't even notice.
Yeah, we just kinda kept it hidden from you, you know?
Yeah, so... Today... We're going to FINALLY clear it up!
Is that okay?
You didn't know.
But we're gonna break it to you.
Don't be too shocked, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's only supposed to be 20 minutes!
20 minutes, but only 20 minutes long.
Most often it's more like 40 minutes, right?
You know, our shortest one was 32 minutes!
It's supposed to be 20!
But it's kinda close to the goal, you know?
Is it?
But recently it's been getting longer and longer and longer and longer.
You know, I think last time was 48 minutes.
Yeah, that's almost 50 minutes.
That's like two episodes of FUWAMOCO Morning in one, right?
Right.
It's only 20 minutes.
Yeah.
So, Ruffians, we want you to understand.
FUWAMOCO Morning is supposed to be only 20 minutes long.
Whether we'll actually get there though,
That's the next question.
That's up to us, right?
It's up to FUWAMOCO!
We'll do our best.
But... I don't know how good we can do.
Thank you Ruffians for believing in us, right?
You believe in us, right?
We can do it!
Let's continue!
Okay!
Well, next we have something new.
We have a challenge.
Today's challenge is not just trying to get FUWAMOCO Morning to be 20 minutes, but today we're going to start our day with this.
Something new.
You know, because
It's good to challenge ourselves to something new every day.
Particularly this challenge is for Moco-chan, you know?
Ruffians, you know, I told you before that I really, really like to eat.
Natto in the morning.
I have it every day.
And if you don't know what natto is, it's fermented soybeans.
And you know, it's really, really, really healthy for you.
It's like a superfood among superfoods.
Maybe it's a little bit slimy.
Maybe it's a little bit... It has a bit of a scent to it.
A scent.
Yeah, maybe some people might say it's a bit... Pungency.
It has a scent to it, you know?
It's not the worst part.
It's full of vitamin K2!
And it's really good for you.
You know, Moco-chan, you don't really like it, right?
I like it!
I want to like it, but I can't.
But Ruffians, Moco-chan's tummy is really important, right?
Your tummy is important too.
My tummy is good because I eat natto every day.
But you know, it's been hurting with all the screaming and the scary stuff.
And playing a lot of intense games, right?
So today, I thought that this would be the day that Moco-chan eats natto.
Conquer the natto, right?
I have to conquer it today.
I thought it would be like a, let's try, let's get there.
Today's the day.
I'm gonna slowly, okay?
I'm gonna do my best, okay?
I'm not gonna... I can't do it all.
So we have one pack here with us today.
I gotta do the thing, I gotta do the thing.
Moco-chan's gonna do her best to eat all 50 grams of it.
It's from Tochigi Prefecture.
Tochigi, thank you.
Thank you, Tochigi.
But if Moco-chan doesn't eat it all, I will!
Okay, Moco-chan, here we go!
Okay.
Eat some more.
And we're gonna eat it without any tare, no sauce.
No mustard.
I have a tissue.
I'm prepared.
It looks delicious.
Okay.
Moco-chan!
You have to do the stuff, okay?
Ruffians, should I stir it up lots for Moco-chan?
No, no, I don't want it to be fluffy!
You get more vitamins!
No, I don't want it fluffy!
It was fluffy with vitamins!
Let me have it not fluffy first, okay?
Okay, Moco-chan, do you need me to feed it to you?
No.
No?
You're gonna do it?
I'm gonna try.
I can't say if I'm gonna do it or not.
Maybe I'll make it a bit easier.
I'll take this side off for you, okay?
Okay.
Because the natto is really slimy and sticky and there's kind of like strings.
Like magical strings that are made.
Magical strings.
Yeah.
And see if it touches your lips or like the chest or anything.
I hate it!
Don't say that that's rude, Mococo-chan!
Thank you, Tochigi!
And it's really good.
It's when it's still on my lips after eating it.
What does it smell like, Moco-chan?
I can't smell anything.
My nose is broken, so this is good.
Oh, this should be easy, then.
I think it smells kind of like... The whole studio should be just smelling like natto, but I don't smell anything, so this is good.
I'm hungry.
Can you eat it, Moco-chan?
You just have one bean!
I have one bean!
Okay, I have one bean.
I'm prepared.
Are you scared of one bean?
I'm preparing my heart!
Okay!
Okay.
Ruffians.
You're gonna cheer for me, right?
Moco-chan's gonna eat the one single natto bean.
This will be a good improvement.
Okay.
It's not even fluffy.
It's not fluffy yet.
Okay.
I'm gonna try it.
Can you get my tissue ready just in case?
I'm worried, okay?
It's a tissue, not a bucket.
Okay.
Should I put it on my tongue, or just... Ah, you should eat it.
That's the way.
Eat it, and then we'll eat more.
No, just eat it.
Ah.
You can't just swallow it.
You have to make sure you savor it.
Okay!
Here we go!
I'm gonna put it on the very back of my mouth.
You need to taste it.
No, this is getting ready.
It's a small step, okay?
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, now I can smell it.
But I feel like I'm a bit more used to it.
Because I smell it so often.
So it's not that bad.
Okay.
Three!
I'm not psyched!
Two!
No, no, no, I want... From ten.
From ten?
Okay, Ruffians, let's all do it together, okay?
From ten.
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
Seven!
Six!
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
I'm out!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
That's so mean, Ruffian-chan.
It's healthy, it's good for you.
You're gonna scare the ruffians!
I wanna eat it, okay?
Another attempt.
You have to do it again.
That was so bad.
I have tears.
Can I have tea?
No tea, you gotta eat it.
I want tea!
I don't know if the issue was that I put it on the back of my tongue, but then it went to the front of my tongue and then I don't know which was worse.
I got it in my mouth though.
That's good, you got it in your mouth.
Eat it with rice like a normal person.
I don't eat it with rice.
Natto soup is good too.
I'm trying.
Moco-chan has to be as strong as me, so... I'm trying.
I want to!
Just do it again.
No countdown this time.
I feel like it's hurting my tummy.
It's supposed to help my tummy.
That's your emotions hurting your tummy, you know?
I'll pick up another one.
Another one?
How about pick up three beans?
No, it's so sticky.
Yeah, because it's natto, you know?
It's so sticky.
It's natto.
I don't want any other stickiness.
There, it's gone.
Three!
Two!
One!
Wait, where should I put all my tongue?
In your mouth.
Should I chew it?
You should chew it.
Yeah, that way the ruffians can know how it truly tastes.
Okay, I need you to hold this then.
I need to have my tissue just in case.
You don't trust me with the tissue anymore?
I don't know.
Okay.
Because when I chew it, it's going to get sticky in my mouth, right?
I don't know.
The stickiness is just on the outside, I think.
It's like bean on the inside.
Once the bean is in my mouth, then my mouth will be sticky too.
It will be.
Okay!
Three!
Okay, I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do it.
Two!
One!
In it goes!
It's in there.
It's on the tip of the tongue.
Moco-chan!
Eat properly!
It got on my lips!
What happened to your food?
No, no!
It was in my mouth but it was still on my lips!
This is such a sad attempt.
Can you even call this an attempt?
I want tea!
No tea!
Not until you eat the whole 50 grams!
No!
Okay, you eat it.
I give up.
We'll challenge this again, okay?
Hey!
Okay!
This was a success.
This was a successful challenge because it was in my mouth, okay?
It was in your mouth?
Yeah.
Next time, I'll properly eat one piece, okay?
One piece?
You gotta eat it all, Moco-chan.
It was successful.
Can I have tea?
No.
Not until you're fully successful.
Challenge failed.
No!
This was successful.
It was.
Thank you, Tochigi Farmers, for making delicious natto that I will be enjoying very much.
Yeah, it's not a waste.
Just the two pieces.
BAU BAU!
That was sad.
It wasn't.
Welcome to our regular corner for today.
Next, we have our Doggie of the Day!
Which doggy is it today, Moco-chan?
Den!
It's Den!
Ruffy!
Ruffy, right!
Den!
Look at you!
You too are fluffy!
So fluffy, you almost rival me!
Really?
I think you're beat.
What?
No!
I'm more fluffy than Ren, right?
I think you're kidding yourself.
Right, Ruffians?
Right.
But, you know, this is Ren right here.
Just as she's waking up from a nap on the sofa.
Very cute.
I like good naps.
Right?
Just looking at this photo makes me want to curl up with her right there, right?
Right!
Good nap!
All together!
Right, the warm sunlight.
Ben is a doggie made for taking midday naps with, you know?
Silly, sleepy, smiley face.
How do you think she BAU BAUs?
I think it'd be sort of soft, like a blanket.
Oh, like a very well-mannered BAU BAU like me?
Like a fluffy one?
Like, BAU BAU.
Really?
Like a... BAU BAU!
No.
BAU BAU.
A bit, a bit warm sounding.
Oh, a bit warm.
Oh, indeed.
Yeah.
Well, I think, you know, then... If you're trying to avoid taking warm, comfy naps in the sun, then... Then maybe it'll get a bit tricky for you, but...
Also, with Ren being by your side, I think every day will be filled with really good times.
I suggest falling asleep together in the sun.
BAU BAU!
And next, let's see where our ruffians went for a walk.
De-den!
Look at those blue skies!
So high up!
And all the green too!
It's beautiful!
We're glad you took a moment out of your day to head over to the park maybe too!
Even if it's just like a close-by park, you can always... It changes your mood so much, you know?
I wonder though, do you think they have like a swing set or something there?
I think that going on the swings while overlooking the scenery would be really, really fun.
Although sometimes the swings can be super scary, right?
It makes my tummy drop when I go too high.
But you know, this is what good days are made of.
It's hard not to be in a really good mood when the world around you is all like this, right?
It feels like it looks sort of nostalgic.
That's the feel I get.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next, we have our Question of the Day.
What do we have?
Oh!
You've played Zelda on an N64, and will play a couple of games on PS2.
What consoles do FUWAMOCO have access to, and would you like to play on stream if possible?
Any consoles or portables you wish you had?
Our consoles, well, we worked really hard to save up for a lot of them, but either we have our SNES, you know that,
Bored with, right?
But the one we have right now, I think?
I think?
It's not the original one.
It's the second in line.
Yeah, the first one is still old.
Yeah, the first one kind of didn't make it away, luckily, you know?
But that's okay.
We have a good second one now.
And our original N64 we still have.
And we have a thick US PS2.
Yeah, very thick.
Chubby one.
And then we have a thin white Japanese PS2 as well.
We have a Wii somewhere.
I don't know where that is.
I guess Mama Puppy has a Wii U so maybe that kind of counts.
Right?
And then we also have a PS3 and a PS4.
Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy got that as part of a deal and then they just kind of...
Gave that to us right before we went into the cell, so really we haven't used that.
We're not very touched.
And then we have a slate!
As for handhelds, I guess... We had a Game Boy Color, and DS Lite, and...
Maybe you've heard of it, maybe not, but we had an Atari Lynx.
Yeah!
But it was kind of hard to play with, and it took a lot of batteries, it was really heavy.
Really big, yeah.
You need muscle for it.
You know, we didn't really understand the game that we had.
I think it was something like Gauntlet?
Only one game.
Yeah, so...
We don't have it anymore.
It was really, really big.
But I think if we could have any console that we don't have.
Console?
I don't know.
Not really a console, but we'd really like to have a PC-98.
PC-98.
You know, if we could play PC-98 games together with Ruffians, that would be really fun.
I don't think that's gonna happen ever.
I don't even...
I think in general we really do like games, but maybe we're not the greatest at them.
We're not very good at them.
But fun is fun!
We have lots of respect and love.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you for the question!
Ruffians, as you know, we're always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, Doggie of the Day, your walks.
Please, please keep on asking, okay?
Keep on sending your stuff, okay?
Asking the questions, you know?
BAU BAU!
And for our next team, Moco-chan, what do we have coming up here?
We have...
Minecraft!
Revenge.
Revenge is nothing scary.
Last time, things didn't quite go as planned.
There were a couple bumps that prevented us from doing what we set out to do.
But this time, there won't be any issues, right?
Right.
Right!
We're gonna do lots of exploring with as much excitement, you know, just like the day we broke out of the cell, right?
That much excitement.
Where's Nerissa?
I don't know.
Yeah, let's take a look at what I said by the beginning.
Okay.
And hopefully we won't touch anything.
Well, for Minecraft, it's revenge.
But, I haven't forgotten.
I forgot what?
Did you forget?
I haven't forgotten.
But you know what?
I'm gonna wait until she forgets.
And then, when she's not expecting it.
Someday.
I'll make her pay.
What do they say?
Revenge is a dish best served cold?
What?
Slow.
Yeah.
Slow and cold.
Let's take a look at our schedule too.
It's a new schedule.
Yeah!
This week we're going to be playing a bunch of games and a bunch of new games too.
We have the Cruising Shift.
We're going to become baristas.
Yeah!
I want to do latte art.
Before we could do like a heart.
Here's your latte.
I do it just for you!
You just gonna drink it like that?
You're not gonna take a photo?
What is wrong with you?
We'll also be doing our best on the weekend because we're gonna be studying a bunch of kanji.
Hopefully we're gonna be learning some new words.
There's still a lot that we don't know so hopefully this can be kind of a first step towards passing our
JLPT N1, you know?
Good study session.
It's gonna be really hard though.
A lot of our senpai have been playing it.
It's not that easy, so... We're gonna do our best, but we're gonna learn a lot too, I think.
BAU BAU!
Jiggle again!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Wow, I think you know we've gotten to the end of our morning together, but thank you so much for joining us.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Oh, that was fast!
Give me a moment!
Mangle Peach!
BAU BAU!
Turn!
Pero!
BAU BAU!
Exo-Shugan!
Karu-fai!
BAU BAU!
Osty!
Ria!
BAU BAU!
Brando's Mindos!
Echo!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!